der bitcoin kurs sieht dieses jahr aus
wie eine achterbahnfahrt erst gab es ein
rekordhoch dann hat die lamas getwittert
und der kurs baustellen keller
bei all diesem auf und ab frage ich mich
seit einer weile auch ob ich nicht
vielleicht auch in bitcoin investieren
sollte und so nebenher ein bisschen geld
verdienen könnte ich könnte das ganz gut
gebrauchen um demnächst eine tolle reise
zu machen aber ich frage mich natürlich
ob das risiko nicht vielleicht zu hoch
ist und ich das geld das ich investiere
dann am ende in den sand setzte genau
darum geht es in diesem film wenn ihr
euch auch fragt ob es sich jetzt noch
lohnt im bitkom zu investieren
dann bleibt bis zum ende dran denn ich
wäre dann die entscheidung treffen ob
ich ein bitcoin investiere oder mich
lieber die finger davon lassen
[Musik]
was mir wichtig ist vorab dieser film
ist keine anlageberatung und wie ihr
euer geld anlegt oder nicht muss jede
und jeder für sich selbst entscheiden
zuerst will ich jetzt einmal
herausfinden wie viel geld ich denn
überhaupt investieren müsste oder sollte
müssten es ein paar hundert euro sein
und sollte ich das einmal im monat
machen also sehr regelmäßig oder würde
es reichen wenn ich mich traue einmal
einen bestimmten betrag zu investieren
darüber will ich mit margarete hornig
sprechen sie ist bloggerin schreibt über
finanzthemen und hat selbst in witten
investiert schon 2017 bin ich also zu
spät dran würdest du heute auch noch
investieren noch damit anfangen ich
persönlich schon ja die letzten vier
jahre für mich extrem spannend die
entwicklung und auch ich sag jetzt mal
recht turbulent das ist wohl das erste
was man lernt wenn man sich mit bitcoin
beschäftigt der kurs des bitcoin
schwankt sehr stark anfang 2017 kostete
ein coil weniger als 1000 euro
anfang diesen jahres lag der wert bei
24.000 mitte märz dann bei mehr als
51.000 euro umgerechnet mehr als 60.000
us dollar
aber der wird konkurs geht nicht immer
nur nach oben nachdem tesla chef elon
musk im mai zu bedenken gab dass die
herstellung von bitcoins viel strom und
co2 verbraucht sei die kurve so aus ein
krasser einbruch und was sollte ich denn
abhängig machen ob ich bereit bin zu
investieren also ich will niemandem
empfehlen nur in köpfe während zu
investieren man wirklich geld einlegen
möchte wenn man wirklich anfangen möchte
vielleicht für sein alter vorzusorgen
vermögensaufbau zu betreiben also sich
wieder etwas aufbauen will dann sollte
man denn dass es ganz wichtig breit
streuen als in verschiedene
anlageklassen
das heißt
ich investierte sich mein ganzes geld in
bitcoin oder andere guckt ob herum
sondern schaue dass ich auch vielleicht
aktien im portfolio hpt es vielleicht
auch gold also nicht das neue gold
korsischen heißen wie sich ganz
klassisch gold dann müsste sich breit
aufstellen und dann muss ich mal
überlegen was bin ich denn so ein von
risiko typ zum beispiel das ist ganz
ganz wichtig weil je nachdem welches
risiko ich tragen kann und welches ich
auch ertragen kann
soll ich dann den anteil an passten also
wenn ich zum beispiel jemand bin so ich
sage okay also sobald irgendwie mal nach
anderen so ein bisschen schwanger werde
ich schon nervös und schlaflose nächte
dann sollte ich dann vielleicht ein
bisschen weniger inso schwankung starke
volatile es sitzt wie crypto währung
investieren und dann vielleicht eher da
wird man gesagt so klassisch auf
anleihen gehen festgeld vielleicht dann
aber auch er so auf etf setzen
margarete geld mehr als teil einer
anlagestrategie fünf bis maximal zehn
prozent in crypto währung zu investieren
und rechnet mir vor was das konkret
bedeuten könnte wenn ich 10.000 euro
vermögen hätte dass ich investieren
möchte
dann könnte ich 70 prozent in aktien und
etf stecken 20 prozent in anleihen und
10 prozent in crypto währung
wenn ich jetzt ganz am anfang stehe und
sagen jetzt baue ich mir erst langsam
was auch beispielsweise durch aktien
sparpläne durch ets wo ich jeden monat
was weg sprache
dann kann ich das auch so machen dass
ich eben jeden monat diesen kleinen
anteil den ich da investieren mich sind
diese zehn prozent vom gesamtanteil den
ich investieren als ich den dann eben in
grub der währung stecke würdest du sagen
dass so eine mittelfristige option geld
nebenbei zu verdienen bei bit konjunktur
wären es ist tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen schwierig zu sagen gibt es das
noch in 20 jahren also
man weiß es nicht deswegen ist es
absolut klug zu sagen das ist nichts für
meine altersvorsorge
das habe ich aber einfach lust daran zu
partizipieren
die ich auch ganz aufregend ist was da
gerade passiert dann kann man natürlich
sagen jetzt habe ich vielleicht
irgendwie 500 euro übrig und sie das
wirklich als spielgeld und investiert
das darin wenn dann schaue ich einfach
mal was in einem jahr wo ist dann steht
was passiert ist oder vielleicht schon
frühjahr so verdanke dir ich bin total
gespannt wie du dich am ende entscheiden
wie es okay das war auf jeden fall
spannend gerade ich glaube es kommt
wirklich darauf an wie risikobereit ich
bin ob ich das aushalten würde
dass der anteil den kleinsten kaufe so
krass schwanken in ihrem wert ich habe
ein bisschen erfahrung schon mit aktien
und etf also ich kenne das aber das so
wie sie es beschreibt klingt nach einer
krasseren achterbahnfahrt auf jeden fall
den musste ich mir auf jeden fall
bewusst sein wenn ich es wagen sollte
ich mich dafür entscheiden wird kaum zu
kaufen kann ich das über
handelsplattformen sogenannte börsen die
bieten dafür auch apps ab anmelden
verifizieren geld drauflegen und dann
kann man handeln rund um die uhr
mir ist klar dass ich bei den preisen
aktuell für ein paar hundert euro nur
einen bruchteil eines bitcoin bekäme
aber egal wie viel man investiert bei
meiner recherche lerne ich zwei sachen
sind wichtig erstens nicht jeder
anbieter ist seriös expertinnen und
experten raten wir dazu
handelsplattformen zu nutzen deren
partner deutsche finanzinstitute und der
bafin also der deutschen finanzaufsicht
unterliegen
das sind zum beispiel die börse
stuttgart mit koeln.de oder bit walla 2
wenn ich keins kaufe muss ich sie wie
bargeld gut sichern zum beispiel vorher
kann dabei helfen anfängerinnen wie mir
aber auch die börsen apps investieren
oder lieber doch nicht auf instagram
frage ich mal meine volle rinnen und
follower hat jemand von euch da draußen
persönliche frage achtung
hat jemand bitcoin oder in eine andere
kultur ehrung mal investiert würde mich
interessieren weil ich das gerade
überlegen und zwar mache ich dazu eine
neue folge zoomin und mich würde
interessieren was ihre argumente dafür
waren oder vielleicht habt ihr euch auch
dank beschäftigt und sollte am schluss
gekommen dass die finger davon
dann würde mich das auch interessieren
schreib doch mal
es haben schon mehr investiert als ich
dachte auch schon vor jahren sowie
jonathan hat mir viel über märkte
beigebracht und man hatte irgendwie das
gefühl teil von etwas revolutionärem zu
sein
das revolutionäre mit bitcoin gab es die
erste digitale fälschungssichere die
zentrale währung bitcoin kaufen ist also
auch eine investition in die idee und
technologie mittlerweile steht für
jonathan aber etwas anderes im
vordergrund
jetzt kann man einfach kaufen und
annehmen das bitcoin zu einem digitalen
anlageprodukt wird sowie gold darauf
spekuliere ich in letzter zeit hatten
nämlich auch große firmen wie tesla
einen teil ihrer rücklagen in bitcoin
angelegt damit stieg der preis die
hoffnung das eigeninvestment wird dann
noch mehr wert tesla hat übrigens immer
noch geld in bett kann investiert man
kann aber keine autos mehr in der krypta
währung kaufen das hatte tesla erst im
märz noch eingeführt
telmo liefert mir bei instagram aber
auch einen grund skeptisch zu sein
er hat seine bitcoin wieder verkauft
umwelt gründe
dasselbe argument wie von tesla chef
elon musk das finde ich einen wichtigen
punkt wenn ich kaufe muss mir klar sein
bitcoin sind stromfresser
ihre herstellung und jede transaktion
verbrauchen wegen der dafür notwendigen
rechenleistung viel energie
vielleicht tut sich aber darauf bald was
wenn der energiemix hersteller
nachhaltiger wird ich bin jetzt den kauf
von bitcoin echt nur noch ein paar
klicks entfernt da scheint ja total
einfach zu sein trotzdem bin ich mir
nicht so wirklich sicher ob ich es wagen
wollen
deswegen will ich erstmal noch mit zwei
experten sprechen die sich
wissenschaftlich mit dem thema
auseinandersetzen und hören was sie mit
erraten
zuerst peter bofinger er ist professor
für vwl an der uni würzburg bei
wirtschaftsweiser und ist kein krupp
offen ob er mich von meinem vorhaben ab
bringt
und ich denke das wichtigste ist einfach
wenn man jetzt kaufen will wenn man sich
ihre so wie sie das jetzt überlegt wäre
das eine gute anlage für mich dann ist
man gut bei finanzinstrumenten dass man
weiß was man kauft und das sind ja nicht
wirklich klar und spannende der bitcoin
ist dass man ein privates
finanzinstrument kauft das einem einen
anspruch auf nichts gewährt wenn sie der
aktie kaufen haben sie im prinzip einen
anspruch auf das unternehmen wenn sie
alle aktien gekauft haben können dass es
in der anlage kaufen dann hat der
emittent der anleihe ihm gegenüber die
verpflichtung wenn die anleihe fällig
ist ihnen gutes geld dafür wiederzugeben
aber dass die bitcoin kaufen haben sie
einen anspruch auf nichts
würden sie denn wirklich davon abraten
und sagen lassen sie lieber die finger
davon
es kommt darauf an wie sie veranlagt
sind aber es gibt auch noch im spiel
luther und es gehen leute die gehen ins
casino
und wenn sie eben jetzt spaß dran haben
obwohl risiken einzugehen
aber auch sich der tatsache bewusst dass
die große verluste machen können dann
können sie das machen wenn sie jetzt
einen dicken einsteigen abend natürlich
dass die chance kurzfristig vielleicht
auch noch ein oder zwei jahren dass das
weiter nach oben geht aber gleichzeitig
besteht auch das risiko dass das ganze
massiv implodieren kann weil eben bei
einem großen vertrauensverlust in
bitcoin wenig da ist was das ganze dann
stoppen kann
das ist ja diese diesem berühmten blase
die dann platzen könnte können sie malt
beschreiben was das würde das konkret
bedeuten wie sieht es aus wenn die blase
platzt beim medcup jeder versucht halt
wirklich schnell auf wie können zu
verkaufen dann kann das vergleichen mit
der situation eines fussball stadions
das voll besetzt ist
wenn sie dann als einzelne vor ende des
spiels ausgehen möchten ist das kein
problem aber jetzt in panik alle
gleichzeitig versuchen aus diesem
fußballstadion ganz schnell raus zu
kommen dann gibt es eben doch erhebliche
probleme
das ist die gleiche logik jetzt bei
bitkom der einzelne kann jetzt mal
wieder ausgehen kann verkaufen aber wenn
alle gleichzeitig ausgehen wollen dann
kann das in seiner panik kommen also
dieses beispiel fußballstadion und dann
kann es eben tote verletzte geben sprich
der gross kann im massif implodieren
weil nicht als er sagte es ist eben
anspruch auch nichts da ist nichts was
diesen anspruch
irgendwie was den wert nach unten
stellen mobilisieren kann da kein
problem wenn jetzt der axt und kosten
fällt jetzt über leute geben die sagen
ja aber das unternehmen produziert ja
sehr viel das machten die gewinne und
dann gibt es irgendwo im inneren der der
das ganze wieder stabilisiert aber ich
kann da das ganze nun kann es sein dass
er kein halt nach und ist professor
bofinger erzählt mir er habe keine
bitcoin er wolle das risiko nicht
eingehen
anders viele bekannte professor an der
frankfurt school of finance & management
er hat selbst bitcoin sieht darin mehr
als zockerei und glaubt anders als peter
bofinger nicht dass die blase platzt
meine meinung ist und das ist meine
persönliche meinung die müssen andere
leute nicht teilen aber ich bin der
meinung dass die chancen deutlich größer
sind als die risiken momentan deswegen
glaube ich auch dass der begonnen große
chance hat zu steigen aber mit
sicherheit sagen kann das natürlich
niemand was ich bin nicht der meinung
dass da eine blase existiert sondern der
bitcoin hat seinen wert der wert ging
jetzt relativ schnell aufwärts aber es
gibt gute gründe warum dem so ist weil
einfach sich auf der nachfrageseite sich
sehr viel getan hat aus meiner sicht ist
der pikon preis momentan keine blase
dann wären momente wo das passiert und
dann der der bitcoin aber so abrutschen
würde also es gibt wenig szenarien
ehrlich gesagt die einen großen
preisverfall auslösen würden
insbesondere wäre zu nennen
die einen der größten volkswirtschaften
der welt china amerika und so weiter ein
problem mit dem bitcoin bekommt und den
dann war sie versucht zu verbieten oder
zumindest sowie der türkei teile der
nutzung zu verbieten also zum beispiel
den zahlungsverkehr und den zahlungsplan
is muss oder dass zum beispiel china
versucht über die dort ansässigen
bitcoin meinem farmen versuchtes
netzwerk feindlich zu übernehmen das
erachte ich alles irgendwo als na ja
relativ unrealistische szenarien und
doch sind es vielleicht hitze kleine
risiken die momentan noch verbleiben
aber im ergebnis mit nicht der meinung
der bitcoin ist relativ also technisch
gesehen relativ unerschütterlich
momentan stark einschränkende staatliche
regulierung hält philipp santner also
für unwahrscheinlich was sie darüber
hinaus überzeugt die möglichkeit mit
bitcoin weltweit geld in unter einer
stunde zu transferieren
das geht schneller als eine
banküberweisung die mehrere tage dauern
kann
außerdem sind die gebühren geringer was
ihr ganz entscheidend ist die sogenannte
nun bedienen teilt wirklich benennen
niemand kann mich daran hintergrund
bitcoin zu besitzen
und niemand kann mich auch daran liegt
an die bitcoins zu tragen sortieren oder
zu transferieren
das einzige was ich brauche ist strom
und ein internetzugang und ein handy
oder einen computer und dann kann ich
quasi diese bitcoins in unbedingter
weise durch die welt transportieren und
besitzen das heißt unbedingt ist hier
das zentrale wort das bedeutet niemand
kann mich davon abhalten keine bank ein
start keinen finanzamt keine polizei
niemand er glaubt dass der bitcoin
deswegen noch wachsen kann weil es
regionen auf der welt gibt in denen die
menschen auf eine unabhängige
zahlungsmöglichkeit wie bitcoin
angewiesen sind
naja also die die wesentlichen chancen
bei dem thema bitcoin ist dass man hier
an einem aufstieg einer technologie die
sich beteiligen kann
diese aufträge der technologie begann
schon vor einigen jahren und die
technologie verbreitet sich einfach
immer weiter und man kann diesen dabei
sein in dem man ein bitcoin investiert
daran glaubt dass quasi dieser aufstieg
der technologie weiter geht
aber diesen chancen stehen natürlich
auch erhebliche risiken gegenüber ganz
klar okay ich fasse mal zusammen mit
kölns schwankt stark
als anlegerin müsste ich das aushalten
insgesamt betrachtet ist der wert aber
noch über dem vorjahresniveau
die investition ist abstrakter als bei
aktien wo ich in den wert eines
unternehmens investiere das etwas
herstellt sowie vw zum beispiel autos
stattdessen investiere ich in eine
technologie
diese braucht aber viel energie das
belastet die umwelt
dass nun auch große firmen wird keiner
als anlage nutzen steigert den wert
niemand kann das risiko der anlegerinnen
und anleger einschätzen
um mitzumachen kann ich aber erstmal
einen vergleichsweise kleinen betrag
investieren
also ich habe da jetzt ein paar nächte
drüber geschlafen und den bitcoin kurs
intensiv verfolgt und ich habe
beschlossen ich mache ich werde ein
bisschen geld investieren
vor allen dingen weil ich neugierig bin
ich will wissen wie sich das anfühlt
diesen kurs zu verfolgen wenn das eigene
geld mit drin steckt und auch weil ich
neugierig bin zu wissen wie viel geld
ich damit verdienen kann
ob das dann so viel geld sein wird er
sich tatsächlich irgendwann mehr reise
mache das einmal dahin gestellt dass wir
die zeit zeigen vielleicht was ich will
die nächste reise auch ganz anders
finanzieren
was ich aber auf jeden fall bei dieser
recherche gelernt habe ist das thema
bitcoin crypto währung ist super
komplexen da gibt es noch super viel zu
lernen und es ist sicher ein thema was
uns noch in nächster zeit vier begleiten
wird
[Musik]